I know you've been very open about
wanting to revisit Freaky Friday only
recently you managed alien Ryan in my
body that'd be nice but don't kiss him
oh Mom I just had breakfast that's
disgusting if you talked to Lindsay
about this
where would you like to see these
characters she's gotta be a grandma Yeah
I mean
I gotta be a grandma
and uh just watching Lindsay tried to be
a grandma makes me laugh and then me
being a grandma trying to take care of
toddlers makes me laugh so I I'm I'm
assuming it'll be something or it won't
be anything but we don't even know yet
and maybe I read another funny thing
that you you when you get texts from
celebrities you you have like questions
that you ask them of course have you if
you had a question from like you know
Jared Leto if Jared and I didn't work
together so I if but if I texted you
what would you well I don't know him so
I don't have a secret uh connection with
him
um uh it has to be somebody I've worked
with why no no so Lynn said the example
of course when I got a text from her out
of the blue one day I hadn't talked to
her in a year or so I got hey Jamie it's
Lin's
I said prove it and she goes what do you
mean I said what was the song that you
and I tried to learn the rap in the
middle of while we were shooting the
French fry scene in the car in Freaky
Friday when we were stuck in the car for
hours and then she wrote back the answer
which is like I Love You by Justin
Timberlake and it's the clips wrap in
the middle of that song
that we were sitting there with a tape
you know it was a tape deck in the car
and we had a pad and they were shooting
the cameras all around but you know when
they're reloading or whatever we're like
Ma what you want to do okay stop rolling
eat french fries do the scene cut reload
Ma what you want to do I'm in front of
you grab a friend see I can have fun
with too wow
I remember
every line from every movie here is Lori
strode's question in the class in the
1978 movie costain wrote that fate was
somehow related only to religion whereas
Samuels felt that fate was more like a
natural element like earth air fire and
water
that was February 1978. that's
impressive
I was certain that I saw him
watching me what is it like for you to
say goodbye to Laurie was it emotional
duh yes it's emotional it's it's it's
filled with emotions it's it's it's
multi-faceted emotions because it's on
one hand I'm saying goodbye to just
literally the physical crew I work with
my director who I've made three movies
with and and this community of artists
that I work with every day then I am
ultimately saying goodbye if you're a
fan to you
I'm saying goodbye and I'm saying thank
you all at the same time I have only
what I have as a as a human being is
because of Lori Strode and I'm saying
bye to it it all ends now
[Music]
everything good in my life is from Lori
Strode nothing in my life doesn't Trace
back to Lori Strode and so to say
goodbye to her permanently uh is
incredibly emotional filled with
gratitude filled with wonder and
amazement that here I sit on my Beatles
Birthday year
you know talking about her and what
she's meant to people yeah is this
actually goodbye if another creative
team picks up the thread in you know
seven years five seven years you know
what would you be interested in
revisiting Lori I'm interested
there's an Integrity mm-hmm
that I've tried to carry with me
um the the love and respect that I get
because of Lori Strode around the world
because of Jamie it's because of Lori
but Jamie and Lori have ultimately it's
like that glue commercial where they you
know put a little drop and then you can
pull them apart you know we can't pull
us apart and so all of the love and
energy that I get
um about Laurie is really also about me
and it's just this beautiful beautiful
relationship that I'm saying goodbye to
and filled with my gratitude for all of
these years of support I find it hard to
imagine that another creative entity is
going to come up with a way to talk
about Lori and Michael and that
relationship or or that conflict that
that Collision
um you know in a way that's going to
make sense to me David Gordon green out
of the blue in 2017 called me and the
2018 movie was a really interesting idea
you don't believe in the boogeyman
I believe in Michael Myers a deranged
serial killer but
The Boogeyman
well you should what happens to people
when they've been traumatized and
haven't had any mental health support
and that exploded that movie yeah and
this last movie
it also honors the fact that her
daughter has died and you see what a
little mental health support actually
can give a person which is you can live
alongside grief
it doesn't have to overwhelm you and I
think that's important he killed my
daughter but tonight I will kill him
come and get me
and so I think we've said it all yeah
and I just can't imagine
um I mean Guillermo del Toro let's go I
mean you know what I mean I'm sure there
are people who who might but I I don't
think so you can't see it from where
you're sitting right now yeah no and I I
probably also shouldn't like it feels
very complete to me yeah talking about
filming this uh this final showdown
between Lori and Michael David said you
guys you would come in and find ways to
up the bar you came here to kill me so
do it
foreign
I just didn't want it to look like a
movie fight my stunt
um double Ashley is a talented woman
and but she takes her lead from me it's
not vice versa and she really kept
saying what do you want how do you want
it and unfortunately movie fights look
good movie fights to me they just do and
so kind of my directive I think there's
a video going around where I'm a little
bossy in a rehearsal space anything
that's gonna look raw and brutal yeah
as long as it doesn't look like a movie
fight I will be happy I wanted it to
look real I wanted it to look like this
final Conflict was real
and there is a moment where we were
figuring out some I mean it has to be
choreographed right you have to know
what you're doing because we don't want
people to get hurt at the same time
you're gonna get hurt because you're
coming in Conflict I don't care how
prepared you are how padded you are it
doesn't matter you're going to get hurt
but you don't want somebody to get
seriously hurt right you don't want to
break a bone or something because then
you you shut the production down then it
costs money
it's all about money yeah yeah so uh
there was a moment in the battle where
where I was in the room I said what I
really want is
something so unexpected and and brutal
that that just people are gonna be like
wait what yes and I said I wanted you to
do it I want you to do it on camera I
don't want it to be a cut where it's
Ashley I don't want Ashley do it I want
to be me and it's in the movie yeah
because that level of what you're not
expecting to see is that I think that's
important is there a part of you
thinking like What if I
no this is very physical this doesn't
this I don't shake this off the way I
did when I was 19. I don't shake it off
the way I did when I was 19 and I I
certainly was you know I knew I'd been
in a fight the next day for sure yeah
but you know what I mean come on
um
it's a horror movie it's fun don't you
want to see a battle Yeah of course
that's the battle
[Music]